warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised yeah look
this shows the hypocrisy of liberalism
you know liberals are the ones who decry
conservatives for not believing in
science and yet when it comes to this
issue of gender it is the Liberals who
are denying science transgendered
bathrooms have come out of nowhere and
are being jammed down our throat I
guarantee you I guarantee you the next
stop on this train is pedophilia Miryam
heinie from the University of verts burg
and she claims that pedophilia is a
natural sexual orientation just like
heterosexuality you described yourself
as a pedophile you admit that you are a
pedophile yes what this is about will
you really go around about this what
this is this is the mainstreaming of
sexual capacity for people of all ages
but they're doing here is not
necessarily trying to argue it's okay
for adult men deaf sex with little kids
what they're getting around about here
is the idea that little children little
children as young as five and six years
old
younger should be able to have sex with
whoever they want but this is
predictable when we refuse to draw the
line anywhere with regards to these
progressive initiatives they're gonna
take you gonna give them an inch they're
gonna take miles and
miles and find out on this episode of
LED live you know we keep asking where
do you draw the line where is this gonna
go and here we see Glenn Beck he makes a
prediction and then right afterwards we
see a liberal millennial say that he was
just insane
you know he's out there he's nuts
transgendered bathrooms have come out of
nowhere and are being jammed down our
throat I guarantee you I guarantee you
the next stop on this train is
pedophilia I guarantee it I mean the guy
is an absolute [__]
a legendary [__] and now here comes
this genius prediction I guarantee you
pedophilia is next name one prominent
liberal who's argued pedophilia yeah
let's go for it so I don't I don't
disagree this guy probably is not
pushing for pedophilia a lot of the
people who are pushing for this trans
movement are probably not pushing for
pedophilia but like we keep saying where
do you draw the line somebody else is
gonna say I'm a dog you must respect my
rights
I identify as an infant who's to tell
that person they can't have a
relationship with a kid well I identify
as a six-year-old you can't tell me by
law you can't tell me I'm not a
six-year-old I'm thinking how are we
gonna regulate this because what stops
me from saying oh for this five-minute
period where any tease the bathroom
identify as a man so I just use the
bathroom I come out and then note I'm
actually identify as a woman right now
you know how do you how do you regulate
who is there actually trans and who's
not that's actually what's happening in
the sports world if you follow like this
whole males identify as females and then
go in and winning all these things
there's nothing that says right after
they're done competing if they don't go
back
identify with the mail yeah they have to
give back everything that they won so
that's actually happening they're
playing like they're a girl winning all
these things and then right after
they're done hey I'm a male well I think
they are saying that you have to be
transitioning for a year but looking to
get into it yeah but look at Bruce
Jenner who's now Caitlyn Jenner he won
all those medals as a man but in his
mind he's been a woman all this time so
technically he couldn't have won those
medals because you're not allowed as a
woman you're not allowed to play and win
those so does he have to give all those
back now so I mean is he really is Glenn
Beck really just out there I mean making
this prediction is it isn't really that
far-fetched yeah it's interesting what
he's saying now the lesbian gay movement
versus the transgender and how it's kind
of taking us by storm he's making valid
points exactly so here's I mean here's
some news things that are coming up now
that was probably a couple years ago
when he said that pedophilia is natural
and normal according to an academic
presentation last year at the University
of wait for at Cambridge the defense of
pedophiles is well a disturbing trend
and arguments are being made by some
university academics at summer
conferences according to Phillip tram
ovitch a professor at a university in
Japan on the prevalence of pedophilia
the majority of men are probably
pedophiles and Hiba files and that
pedophilic interest is normal unnatural
in human males Sun News contributor
Marissa cmq joins me now in studio ok so
they're probably a lot of guys watching
this right now and saying I'm not a
pedophile I have no I and by the way the
the word Heba foul refers to people who
are in between 11 and 14 Marissa do you
think that there is an increasing push
from academics to let's say push the
boundaries when it comes to what's
acceptable in child sex not just
academics actual political groups with
sort of political objectives but yes
absolutely there are members of the
political and/or rather academic
establishment that are trying to push
the limits on the exact ability of child
sex and
back in 2012 for instance in the House
of Commons doctor jizz and Jem he's a
professor and psychologist at the
University of Montreal this is when they
were debating how to amend the Criminal
Code with respect to sexual crimes
against children I want to pull up a
board of what he said here he said
pedophiles are grappling with what is
equivalent to a sexual orientation just
like another individual may be grappling
with heterosexuality crazy or even
homosexuality and if we agree on the
fact that true pedophiles have an
exclusive preference for children which
is the same as having a sexual
orientation so he uses language like
sexual orientation there that is not
uncommon dr. James canter of CAMH I
recall in an interview with the Toronto
Star said referred to pedophilia as a
sexual orientation this is Canada news
because Canada is really pushing this
you must talk about transgender in
school as early as kindergarten we saw
that the government can take your kids
away if you don't allow them the
transition or whatever I saw an article
of a thirteen-year-old girl where a
school counselor counseled her that she
should have the sex change or she should
go through the transformation and they
told the parents there's nothing you can
do about it and we will press charges if
you try to regardless of whether a
person is predisposed to be that way or
not the pedophilia forces itself on
other people and that is something that
has to be protected because a child
cannot defend themselves
you know against a full-grown male a
full-grown female you know they have no
defense they are young they are a weaker
and it doesn't matter what that person's
preference is if it's that age group you
cannot you know force yourself on other
people there has to be boundaries and a
child looks up to an adult and will
believe a lot of things adult saying can
be easily manipulate
into doing things I think there's enough
evidence to show that parent or adults
that have molested children what that
psychologically does to that child I
mean there is plenty of cases where
these kids lives are destroyed because
of some adults activities with that and
and it's not like the person the
perpetrator his life was totally
destroyed it's it's more of a damage to
the to the young child and historically
speaking if you look at like Rome when
Rome really truly fell I mean sexuality
was was one of the things that kind of
pre cursed that whole demise of that
society and and and all throughout
history if you look at the different
societies that had very loose ideals on
this top this type of a topic it was
never a good ending yeah what do you say
to two people who have grown up that
happened to them and their parents you
know they were abused or molested I mean
he was supposed to say well I'm sorry
that was their preference and we can't
deny them you know I mean there's a
fragmentation that happens in the mind
and so many of those people go on to
abuse drugs you know they abused alcohol
they they struggle with depression you
know I don't I don't think we can just
have a free-for-all and say well you
know whatever you want because it's what
you identify with do you think that you
know everyone else has boundaries except
for trans people and what I mean by that
is if they go ahead and say that
pedophilia is a sexual orientation which
god I really hope that doesn't happen um
like legally you know if there are an
offender they have to be put on the
registry right they have to be they have
to live a certain proximity away from
school and all these things as a woman
if I enter into a men's bathroom man can
call the cops and I could be arrested if
I don't leave and things like that but
with a trans person it's like
that's not set in place like there
doesn't seem to be any boundaries really
you know I can't really call and report
a trans a trans woman who comes into the
bathroom because now there's lots to
protect that but if I go into a man's
without their own you know it's a
problem
hmm it's like where are the boundaries
yeah that's the overarching question
here is where the boundaries where do we
draw so I want to mention something real
really quick there at the notice how
that tag line on that that news thinks
had born this way mm-hmm I want to make
a comparison to in Christianity you know
the whole homosexual movement is I was
born with this type of orientation like
why are you getting upset at me I did
not choose this this is what's been
given to me since my birth
but at the basic core understanding of
what it means to be a Christian as well
we have that same argument as well I was
not at the tree of knowledge of good and
evil I did not choose that piece of
Apple to eat that caused all this sin to
happen I am born into this situation but
there's two ways to look at this one is
I'm gonna embrace my lifestyle embrace
myself in this sinful world and
celebrate it or I believe that God has a
transformation message and can actually
help me overcome these types of things
that's that's really what the argument
is and that's why I think that we see
this in a Christian sense so heavily
being thrown out into our world right
now because it hits at the core of what
it means to be a follower of God now to
a story about one of the most sensitive
subjects imaginable the abuse of
children there are some people who think
attitudes and actions towards pedophiles
should be adjusted correspondent shannon
bream explains
a small group of psychiatrists and other
mental health professionals is
advocating changes to the way the
American Psychiatric Association defines
pedophilia in the diagnostic and
statistical manual of mental disorders
or DSM saying those they call minor
attracted persons are being unfairly
stigmatized instead a psychiatric term
gets turned into something that's just a
demonizing pejorative that troubles me
Wow so i mean i don't believe that glenn
beck was making some outlandish
prediction you know we're seeing it
happen step by step and even what's
socially acceptable on netflix this is
their official YouTube channel this is
the show that they show on Netflix and I
mean you have this is a it's a show
about prepubescent children who are
going through puberty and there's scenes
of them naked I mean are we really
trying to normalize this entertain
ourselves with children and sexuality
we're mixing this and and I've tried to
speak out against this show on social
media and was attacked for it
don't talk about my favorite show I wish
this show was out when I was a kid
because I've learned so much from it or
I would have learned so much from it if
I was you know raised on this well you
know statistically we know that that
teens say that they actually learn a lot
about sexuality from the media yes it's
one of their primary sources of
information and so that kind of doesn't
surprise me you know because people feel
like they're at a lack of information
and it really falls back on their
parents is at some point you need to be
communicating these things to your
children and teaching them about
sexuality and teaching them about
biology and helping them understand
their responsibility
in this world and their responsibilities
to God and you know how to behave
appropriately how to take care of your
body all those things but if it's not
being taught at home of course you're
gonna look for it somewhere you know and
there are a myriad of opinions on the
internet
so Netflix even showed a movie called
desire where the opening scene had like
a twelve-year-old girl
pleasing herself and and the scene was
on the movie and it's like are we
getting away with this now this would be
considered child pornography straight up
but now this is the norm entertainment
man I really questioned the parents of
these kids that I would allow them to be
on a show like this yeah did you read it
the parent the mothers were on the set
oh they have to be oh yeah when you're
under a certain age I think it's 18 and
under your mother or father has to be on
set with you they are they are agreeing
to this kind of activities happening
there's not somebody that's dropped off
and allowed to do whatever and there's a
lot of exposing going on now of
pedophilia in Hollywood and you know
they're just loving this but they have
to go you know their kids might be taken
away if they don't do what the kid tells
them they want to do it's a valid point
and the opening scenes to little girls
who look to be about 7 and 9 are playing
horse on pillows the older girl begins
to obviously masturbate as younger child
watches the camera even takes the scene
this scene into a close-up of the
child's face in slow motion moving up
and down and panting like a porn star
the scene is graphic and includes an
orgasm
there's one thing that came to mind you
know the aftermath of all of this let's
say this does and I even know if it's or
has already become a law where children
are literally being taken away from
their parents because of X Y & Z who's
taking care of these kids where are
these kids going what's happening to
them
you know what where does that work
responsibilities fall is the government
ready to take care of all these kids
were under 18 are doing whatever or have
the understanding that I can do whatever
I want
why did they need somebody to take care
of them if they have the capability to
call their own shots and imagine those
kids as adults if they're not able to
fall under the rule of their parents
what makes you think they're gonna fall
under the rule of the law later on in
life that's a good point
there's no set standards so the Bible's
out of the question he's saying this is
a sexual orientation like being
heterosexual like being homosexual it's
not something that can be changed is
that accurate he's saying it's
orientation fixed from birth which some
of the research is showing now it's hard
to measure because you know children
don't have sex or look at pornography or
all the things that we might use to
measure sexual orientation so we really
don't know but but an orientation is
different from a compulsion and one of
the things we know about pedophiles is
that they are often compulsion
compulsive by the way pedophilia is when
there's more than five years age
difference between the perpetrator and
the victim and the victim is
prepubescent so let's call him someone
who has a sexual orientation towards
children we don't know if he's really a
pedophile bring him in he's a name is
Todd this is the man who wrote the
article he says he is a pedophile he is
a moderator for a website virtuous
pedophiles VI ver ped org and Todd you
were young teenager when you first
realize you're attracted to children is
that accurate that's correct
and what goes and what did you do to
combat this howhow are we I mean I think
some people would be skeptical when you
say I've controlled these urges well
when I was 13 I repressed a lot of it I
kind of felt like it was a you know it
was something that I would get past
eventually it didn't really on it too
much at times and Todd you had sexual
abusive childhood is that accurate yes
and you became a drug addict also right
yeah but that had to do with
when I was depressed and well but being
unregulated being traumatized that
that's you know most I would say a
hundred percent of my patients well for
sure if you had bad enough addiction
that you needed to see me when I was
running a program you had physical or
sexual or both abused in childhood it's
the way it goes but but so drug
addiction is set up by this many times
my question that is how do you know what
you did when you were loaded well I
never got that high I took a few
hydrocodone just to kind of deal with
the pain I was working out every day you
know so I was in physical pain a lot
from that because I was depressed and
you know when you're depressed you your
brain doesn't deal with the it doesn't
produce the chemicals that todd todd I
want it I want to get some info for oh I
didn't see if you don't mind yes sir go
ahead I just have a question about what
support exists for that if we're saying
that it is like alcoholism is there
programs is there support to prevent
people that have come out as saying like
this is something I'm it's creating a
community he's creating a community so
that if you have these feelings as
opposed to acting out on them which is
the horrible crime that means that a
child is being put in that position you
go to this community and you try and
work through with other peers also deal
about mental health issues that we don't
deal with in this community for
treatment or is he going to the
community to talk about having sex with
children it's like a drunken log at an
immediate virtual pedophile so so what
does that mean I know you're a pedophile
virtuous I think I said virtuous I think
this was an episode on Law & Order SVU
where there's this whole organization
shut up you know look but don't touch
virtuous pedophile so they they
understand who they are and they kind of
own it and and are okay with it they
would never they know they understand
it's wrong so they would never touch a
child but potatoes are right some of
them did I believe so yeah I mean this
is from watching the show but I'm sure
it's I guess one of the observing is it
just that day children is it just
children that they're observing
to pleasure themselves yes but they
would never touch it and in under almost
every single circumstance that I know in
this country that's illegal
that's child pornography in you Oh
totally yeah that's why they got you're
down at the end of the day but I'm just
saying from a virtuous pedophile they're
thinking you know this is who I am so
it's okay to watch especially I would
just never touch a child that is just
like you know going up to that forbidden
tree and well I just want to touch it
you know it's it's a gateway drug you
know it's like if you allow this or
maybe another step you know they're just
gonna crave the real thing really want
the real thing you know
[Music]
[Applause]
something differs in the hospital fold I
thought they were doing it for some
charity or a cause if it is not then I
think it charges things up no end more
than area what is actually going on
[Music]
secret life of the human okay I mean off
of just observing this you know I think
God made a distinct separation between
the animals and the humans and this is
just dragging humanity down to an
animalistic level and I mean it's just
it's quite sad
those who believe that we're all on the
same playing field you know humans and
animals they wouldn't agree with this
yeah I mean you know can't even breathe
crossbreed between the species and are
you sure her knows man
so freak show yeah so I mean if we must
accept that these people are animals the
opposite gender
this guy identifies as a child who used
to tell this guy he cannot have a
relationship with another child I mean
even 13 year-olds date right with
interesting is he looks young in the
face and how much makeup he's wearing to
try and make himself look younger you
know check it out well Brett documented
a day in the life of his infant ilysm
take a look this is something I wanted
to show you guys the crib was made by
one of my best friends I got the crib
design from online for an actual adult
baby crib the crib altogether was around
350 to 500 dollars money well spent in
my opinion thank you happy this is the
chair I made right after my crib it's a
high chair it's three and a half feet
off the ground
this probably costs around two hundred
fifty to four hundred dollars to do all
together I throw stuff off here I have
tantrums ie I get messy
oh the food was on the trailer I'm in my
baby chair and I'm good to go dude where
where are we going man he's not alone
this was just the one like shortest clip
I could find basically well I guess I
guess my question is if you are an
infant I'm assuming he doesn't drive
because why would he need a license you
know children don't drive and there are
other rights and responsibilities as an
adult that would be revoked guessing no
I'm gonna go back to this same sort of
thing I suppose that if you want to live
your life in this way then you have the
right to live your life that way I you
know as crazy as we may think this
inside but if but it's crazy we think
this is that's the freedom that we all
extend to everyone else where I find it
to be a problem is if that is now
forcing his belief system or anything
else on everyone else you don't have to
live your life that way and you don't
even have to engage in that you know
what I mean but if if that's what he
really truly feels and he wants to live
his life accordingly to that and he
wants to be a baby he should be able to
do that I agree with that I mean this
transgender thing you remember they said
at the beginning on Bill Nye it's not
just adults there's kids now and it's
being celebrated this kid was on USA
Today or something you know that the
taste show and they paraded him out and
he's all dancing around flamboyant like
a woman and and they're just praising
him for being who he is but this was a
clip that I found you know he's not with
his parent this is not his parent this
is some adult alone on live webcam does
anybody know what ketamine is you ever
heard of it it sounds familiar but I'm
not recalling so we're for adults we
don't even know what ketamine is I want
you to check out this clip real quick
your mom can do jazz no genders what has
this world come to it's come to a world
where drag kids actually exist then
people do ketamine on a couch people do
ketamine on a couch and this kid goes
what do ketamine on a couch he knew what
it was
ketamine is a medication mainly used for
starting and maintaining anesthesia it
induces a trance-like state while
providing pain relief sedation and
memory loss
other uses include for chronic pain
sedation and intensive care and
depression he snorted he's with someone
who's not his parent an adult on camera
and and this kids being praised Desmond
is amazing as his name as stage name
[Music]
what had this world come to it's coming
to a world where this is a 21 and up
club he has men hooting and hollering
and giving him money
this is what city they actually have in
New York Manhattan they have a huge
picture of his face because he's like a
celebrity now this is a club called
Oasis in New York City 21 and up old men
giving him money as he strips I don't
see how that's legal well it's on camera
and they announced yeah the club oh it's
a transgender Club see there we go again
with boundaries hmm yeah I've I
literally think that there is probably
way more of this going on than what
we're even exposed to in little media
clips like this this is this is where
this endgame is bringing everyone to
there's no way to have a clear distinct
line what's right and what's wrong and I
mean where's this kid's parents well yes
he's traveling around a lot and hanging
out with a bunch of transgender people
on their webcast and all this and
there's nothing there's nothing being
done about this this isn't like some
underground video like he's a celebrity
and the club is well-known and nothing's
being done about it
this is just accepted now and here he is
with this guy named Michael who if you
ever seen the movie party monster
they started the club kid scene where
all they did was get messed up on drugs
and dress up like you know they express
themselves through clothing the
interesting thing about this video is
the artwork that he is the standing
behind him this guy painted it Michael
painted it and this word this is a
desperate is amazing episode our special
guest the amazing dez-mo
all the same intoxicated drove through
rush-hour traffic to get here
hot tea is 9:40 p.m. and he doesn't have
to go to school today
the date rape drug
oh this is the guy who he's sitting next
to this is his artwork
so that's kind of scary that Mickey
Mouse with yeah look at this oh wow
sorry but we should introduce you
explain the viewers who doesn't it
desert is the world's youngest club kid
and we challenge you around there to
find a younger club kid will they find
one no they're calling him a club kid he
knows what ketamine is he imitated
snorting it now he's hanging out with
these guys their whole life is clubbing
you see that the date-rape drug on the
painting and he in my opinion looks he
looks hot
intoxicated on something yeah he days
Wow and this yeah the the makeup the
lipstick I mean you know the reason why
females have the dark and the smeared is
is is really as it looks like they've
been there working working yeah they're
working girl and this is disturbing but
he is being praised he's being invited
on all the shows
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey so this is Jared on Instagram and is
that ham with the kid that's not him
that's another one the word boundaries
could just keep popping into my mind
it's just like you know this is a child
okay if the child identifies as
transgendered okay and you even you know
allow the child to just certain away and
all these things fine but now you're
taking this step further in immersing
him into this culture letting him do the
same thing that go on adults consenting
able to consent adults are doing and
saying that it's fine for this child to
do it and you know nothing's gonna mess
that brain is not fully developed until
the mid-20s
I think and even I mean nobody's gonna
argue even psychological scientists will
tell you that a child's brain is not
even can't make these logical decisions
so I mean this this really I think that
there should be some legal action
against their parents I mean this really
this should be legal nationally
interviewed a photograph by queen lacet
like for Hut
zyne this isn't just somebody in their
basement instagramming something like
these are well-known people and they're
it's in a magazine like this is where
we're going this is paraded and praised
the these pedophiles they're there
fantasizing but they're not acting out
Snopes was a website that they they
loved just shut down conspiracies like
they will debunk anything but they
really do their research and there was a
claim that child sex doll products were
briefly available on Amazon they found
out it was true this lady took a
screenshot of it the idea is that this
can medicate
a pedophile without them acting out like
I said this is a gateway drug this has
given them a taste of what they've been
fantasizing about and they're only gonna
keep pushing to get the real thing so we
hope you were blessed by this video we
just fill a burden that we need to talk
about this because chances are there's
probably a pedophile in every church and
you don't even know it and this stuff's
getting more normalized so we just feel
like you need to talk to your children
about this be prayerful about wins the
right appropriate age to talk about it
but it just needs to be address because
we need to be vigilant we need to know
what's what's out there so help us to
help you write a comment let us know
what you think about the video tell us
what we should be talking about because
we want to be relevant we want to keep
informing people so click the
subscription click the notification bell
and keep coming back for more
keep comment and if you want to support
this ministry you can do so through
patreon and we we have a lot of cool
perks for our donors we love you guys
keep coming back god bless you
[Music]